all right so they say stone falls freely
the time taken to fall I'm gonna write
that down time taken to fall and I
encourage you to do this as well right
like do you notice there are no
pronumerals in the question I'm gonna
use pronumerals in a second but I'm
introducing them so I should probably
say what they are so this is what they
do talk about time taking a fall and
then there is distance fallen so these
are the two quantities that they are
interested in being that these are the
two quantities I am going to give them
names what's a common sense name for
time T I'm gonna go with age okay and
distance fallen okay easy so they say
that time taken to fall varies directly
with uh with square root of the distance
so T varies directly square root of the
distance okay so I can now form my
equation which is T equals what yep
there's my constant parameter okay so
now to find out what K is because I'm
gonna need that to actually answer the
question I use the data that's been
provided for seconds matches up with
seventy eight point four meters so
seconds goes in time for and seventy
eight point four goes in my distance so
from here I just want K so I'm going to
divide both sides by the square root of
seventy eight point four
okay you don't need to I don't think it
says at any point you need to actually
evaluate that you can just leave it
there
yeah you just use it like that okay now
they want to know how long that's T time
how long will it take for it to go 500
meters so here's the last thing I said
about T and D together so using this
number I can say that T is 4 on the
square root of 78 point 4 times the
square root of what what distance are we
talking about right now 500 like so and
now the rest is calculator work it is
very important that we put down our 10
point 0 6 give me a few more did someone
is a grizzard disappear do 305 9.8 over
dot okay and then at the last moment you
then look at the question and it says to
the nearest second and that's when you
round you saw the six you saw on the
sticks you know what they that's that's
not your fault because what your brain
is done is look for the next one after a
zero that's why and you're like there's
the zero whoops you know say very human
error to make okay